well i'm a very competitive person and
when i was 19 i decided i wanted to be
the best in the world at something i
found marathon swimming at 22 and
started swimming the english channel at
24 and i just love the channel it's like
my spiritual home and i just wanted to
go after amazing records and put my name
in history against people i really
admire who have done incredible things
in in marathon swimming
um
what's the biggest challenge when you're
doing it how cold the water is
yeah definitely not so much for single
crossings but for double crossings
that's over to france and back again
non-stop or triple crossings the hardest
thing is that i might get hypothermia so
severe that i need to be admitted into
icu so intensive care in hospital or
potentially this worst case scenario i
could die so i was hospitalized in 2011
in canterbury my core temperature was 28
degrees and i also had swimming-induced
pulmonary edema and that's when blood
leaks into the lungs from the heart so
it can potentially be a very uh
life-threatening slush challenging sport
but with single crossings because i'm
only in there 10 to 12 hours that issue
isn't really there and i yes so two days
ago i just really enjoyed that swim that
hopefully my final swim and um i didn't
worry about hypothermia at all
so why have you stopped now why not go
for 45 or 50 or 100
yes yes there's been many people asking
me that and um because i've swum so much
they kind of assume i'm just gonna keep
going i think everyone needs to have a
point where they can stop and just soak
in and feel like they've come to a
completion or an end of a journey and i
want to have that with channel swimming
i'm very happy with 44 um the the queen
of the channel before me allison street
i admired her so much look i don't feel
any need to do any more crossings but in
saying that i am very proud to now have
this world record so if alison comes
back and starts from the channel more
then yes i will bump it up to 45 or 50
or whatever i need to make sure
australia has that crown for as long as
possible
now you've said about how bad it is with
the cold what about jellyfish and big
boats
the jellyfish they don't really bother
me i've been stung by deadly jellyfish
in the caribbean which was much much
worse the shipping lanes that go through
the english channel for me they're just
mesmerizing they go in opposite
directions it's the busiest shipping and
also ferry lane in the world so when i'm
swimming along i'm actually sometimes
just gazing around and all the
incredible things i can see around me
for me it's never really been an issue
in my swims the pilots that's the boat
captain next to me with the boat they're
constantly carefully navigating through
those shipping lanes they do it very
well it's very safely managed the coast
guards on the english and french side
are in constant communication with my
boat captain and it's the same with
other swimmers very well managed
okay so if not the um english channel
then then what next one would have
thought somewhere up the gold coast
would be much more enjoyable
yeah yeah definitely well i do i'm an
amateur athlete so i don't get paid to
do marathon swimming and i've always
been working as well as my marathon
swimming career so i do a lot of keynote
speaking to schools and business and i
coach people to swim the english channel
it's looking forward to doing more of
those things i really enjoy outside
doing laps of the channel
okay chloe congratulations well done
amazing 44 crossings of the english
channel i've not even done that on a
boat so it's just absolutely spectacular
well done you
thank you bye thank you bye